en este vídeo vamos a analizar con mayor
detalle la utilidad de la tabla
periódica de los elementos en particular
nos vamos a enfocar en los grupos de la
tabla periódica y cuando hablamos de
grupos nos referimos a las columnas como
vemos aquí aún cuando los elementos de
cierta columna pueden tener números
atómicos diferentes todos tienen
propiedades similares y la razón es
porque en la mayoría de los casos tienen
el mismo número de electrones de
valencia recordemos que los electrones
de valencia son electrones reactivos
aquellos que pueden interactuar con
otros elementos y debido a que los
elementos con electrones de valencia
similares reaccionan de forma similar
formarán iones similares y tendrán
papeles similares en compuestos iónicos
ahora para el propósito de este vídeo
nos vamos a enfocar en particular en los
extremos de la tabla periódica los
grupos de la izquierda y de la derecha
porque estos son los más cercanos a
llenar su nivel energético exterior ya
sea al perder electrones o al ganar
electrones veamos como repaso qué
significa tener el nivel
energético exterior completo bueno en
general las personas se refieren a la
regla del octeto para el segundo tercero
cuarto quinto y los siguientes el nivel
exterior estará lleno cuando tenga ocho
electrones la mayor excepción a la regla
del octeto es el primer nivel que se
llena con dos electrones así que el
helio aunque sólo tiene dos electrones
es mucho muy estable el mayor dato que
tenemos alrededor de esta regla del
octeto es el grupo 18 que está por aquí
también conocido como el de los gases
nobles y se conocen como los gases
nobles porque son no reactivos son muy
tranquilos y no quieren meterse con
nadie más y esto es debido a que todos
los gases nobles tienen llenos sus
niveles exteriores el nivel exterior del
helio es el primer nivel y está lleno el
nivel exterior del neón es el segundo y
está lleno el nivel exterior del argón
es el tercer nivel y está lleno y así
sucesivamente ahora si vamos al grupo a
la izquierda de los gases nobles
llegamos a los halógenos los halógenos
tienen 7 electrones de valencia por lo
que es
pueden imaginar que sólo les falta un
electrón para tener la configuración de
electrones como la del gas noble que
está a su derecha por lo que estos
halógenos quieren atraer electrones para
formar un ión negativo o una unión por
eso muchas veces vemos el flúor como una
unión de floruro porque tiene una carga
negativa o también vemos al cloro con
una carga negativa como el avión de
cloruro y así podemos continuar
frecuentemente vemos que el yodo gana un
electrón y tiene una carga negativa si
nos movemos a la izquierda llegamos al
grupo del oxígeno el azufre y demás
estos elementos tienen 6 electrones de
valencia por lo que es más fácil para
ellos tener un nivel completo al ganar
dos electrones que perder 6 electrones
así que a estos elementos también les
gusta atraer electrones por lo que
podemos ver al oxígeno como una unión de
óxido ha ganado 2 electrones que le ha
quitado a otro elemento el azufre lo
encontramos como añón de sulfuro ahora
si vemos el otro extremo de la tabla
periódica y nos fijamos en los elementos
del grupo 1 tienen un electrón de
valencia y especialmente para qué
que vemos en color rojo aquí que se
conocen como metales alcalinos es mucho
más fácil perder un electrón para tener
un nivel completo que ganar siete
electrones la razón por la que el
hidrógeno es una excepción es porque no
tiene que ganar siete electrones para
tener un nivel exterior completo sólo
tiene que ganar uno así que el hidrógeno
puede perder uno y esencialmente no
tener electrones o podría ganar un
electrón y tendría una capa completa
como el helio pero cuando pensamos en
compuestos iónicos estos metales
alcalinos son realmente unos de los
participantes más interesantes porque
como se pueden imaginar para que sean
estables tienen que perder un electrón
por lo que es muy probable que nos
encontremos con un electrón - y una
carga positiva así que frecuentemente
vemos un ión de litio con una carga
positiva y un ion de sodio con una carga
positiva unión de potasio con una carga
positiva y esto en general se cumple
para todos los elementos del grupo 1
ahora que hay de los elementos del grupo
2 también conocidos como metales
y no te ríos una vez más es más fácil
para ellos perder dos electrones que
ganar seis para tener una carta completa
así que típicamente vemos el berilio con
dos cargas positivas y habrá perdido dos
electrones
el magnesio tendrá dos cargas positivas
el calcio tendrá dos cargas positivas
ahora dado esto como esperaríamos que
los elementos de la izquierda y los de
la derecha forma en compuestos iónicos
pueden adivinar que si tenemos un metal
alcalino en presencia de un halógeno las
cosas podrían volverse muy reactivas
porque estos quieren dar un electrón y
estos quieren ganar un electrón y eso es
lo que va a ocurrir los electrones
dejarán a los elementos del grupo 1 y se
irán al de los halógenos y en este
proceso se puede liberar mucha energía
pero lo que queda es un compuesto iónico
por ejemplo el litio pierde un electrón
y tiene una carga positiva ese y un
positivo podría ser atraído a la unión
de cloro que justo ha ganado un electrón
y quizá es el mismo electrón o lo obtuvo
de otro átomo de litio por lo que estos
dos elementos se van a atraer iban a
formar cloruro d
y todos estos metales alcalinos jugarán
el mismo papel del litio en este
compuesto iónico es típico ver el
cloruro de sodio que es sal de mesa
también es normal encontrar el cloruro
de potasio y así sucesivamente por otra
parte el flúor el bromo y el yodo pueden
tener el mismo papel que el cloro por lo
que podemos encontrar yoduro de sodio o
yoduro de potasio nuevamente los metales
alcalinos habrán perdido un electrón los
halógenos habrán ganado un electrón y
ambos se atraerán mutuamente para formar
estos compuestos iónicos qué tipos de
compuestos iónicos podríamos formar con
estos elementos del grupo 2 veamos el
calcio por ejemplo es razonable para el
calcio perder 2 electrones para tener un
nivel exterior estable para tener una
configuración de electrones como el
argón así que si éste pierde los
electrones tendrá dos cargas positivas y
podemos imaginar que esos dos electrones
se pierden en los átomos diferentes de
yodo por lo que cada uno de ellos tiene
una carga negativa a veces dos y
entonces qué tipo de compuesto iónico
podría
bueno podemos tener un calcio y luego
dos yo dos así que el yoduro de calcio
es en realidad un compuesto iónico
podemos ver que tiene una carga neutral
general porque el calcio tiene dos
cargas positivas y cada uno de los
diodos tiene una carga negativa pero
tenemos dos de ellos así que es neutro
en general que puede hacer el calcio con
el oxígeno bueno al calcio le gusta
perder dos electrones al oxígeno le
gusta ganar dos electrones así que
podemos ver algo como óxido de calcio
aquí terminamos la idea general es que
la columna en la cual el elemento se
encuentra nos dice mucho sobre su
reactividad porque nos dice en general
cuántos electrones de valencia tiene y
como los átomos son más estables cuando
tienen completo su nivel exterior nos
ayuda a predecir si es más fácil para
ellos perder electrones y formar un ión
positivo o ganar electrones y formar un
lío negativo y a partir de ahí podemos
hacer predicciones sobre los tipos de
compuestos iónicos que podrían formarse
con los diferentes elementos